好,謝謝,我說今天可能第三次,我再講一次利率吧
因為我覺得最近一兩個月來關注利率人特別多
然後基本的看法也沒有什麼變化
就其實根據星期五出來的新的經濟數據
然後我們把利率在最後梳理一下
就是星期五的經濟數據本身是特別好
就是那個能放配入特別好
這個跟我們預期不一樣
就是我之前覺得能放配入數據會很差
數據雖然很好,但是數據本身並沒有一定指向通脹
我覺得是星期五的數據告訴我們這個點
就是它的數據很好,中間帶著周期性
然後帶著周期性的數據,所以它並沒有直接指向通脹
然後我它會說一下大家比較擔心的一件事情
就是代表擔心的就是它真的如果加息會怎麼樣
那麼我先說個結論,我覺得真的加息也沒有怎麼樣
就是加息其實並不是一定引爆風險資產
這我再次重申一下,現在的經濟是一個K shape
那我們上兩星期都已經講過這個問題
是一個K shape的經濟,那麼真的加息
我覺得就是說你覺得它對市場衝擊會有多大
其實是有兩個關注點,就是你去關注這些東西
然後但是我覺得現在來看這些指標都還OK的
那沒有特別大的問題
我們安不就斑馬
說一下那個非農休業的數據
然後非農的16.2萬,如果你看這條線的話
它而且把上次那個負的給 adjust
就把上次那個負的給調整
那個16.2萬的這個數據如果放在過去的話是非常好
但是中間有兩個有幾個問題
就是第一個是它這裡面休閒旅遊和休閒旅遊
還有政府就相當於local government education
就是地方政府的教育
這兩個數據相當是主要增長的部分
那麼休閒旅遊裡面
通常來說8月份的時候是會進行一個負面
就是8月份一般來說比較清淡
所以它8月份的時候它會做一個seed on adjustment
就會做一個那個季節性的調整
然後但是美國8月份是正好是世界盃
所以世界盃的時候雇員98的雇員就非常多
98雇員增加了59k萬,919
相當於這裡面大部分是98雇員增加
然後local government education要開學了嘛
所以這個雇員也是有季節性的
所以這一次的數據裡面雖然它是個正的
比我們預期還需要好
然後雖然這數據是正的
但是裡面有大半的這個就業本身是帶著季節性因素
或者是特別是世界盃是有個更加強的季節性的因素
所以你不能說它有這個數據導致經濟過熱
那可能現在我感覺就是這個數據
肯定是沒有辦法證明它過熱的
那麼這個數據會不會證明
沒有辦法證明它經濟上過熱
會不會證明上它經濟導致它通脹呢
那我覺得通脹也沒有
就是幾個就是hourly wage
就小石心小石心吧
薪水那麼薪水這個東西跟我們叫做service
就最最嚴重的那部分通脹
通脹三部分那個service
然後房租
然後輸入性的產品
那麼現在通脹更多的是來自於第三部分
就產品
一方面是關稅後續的影響
一方面是石油那些輸入性的影響
但是小石的薪水一直沒有看到抬頭
那麼這個也是從今年開始
26年開始就基本上一直沒有看抬頭
這個就是我們認為通脹不太可持續行
就是現在沒有可持續行通脹的一個很重要的原因
那麼小石心的薪水比預期要高
所以你說3.1比預期高是不是帶動通脹呢
我覺得並不是
相反這個數據更多的是給市場
一個覺得經濟基本面還是比較堅硬的
這麼一個沒有證明有通脹的情況下
給市場一個認為就是經濟基本面還是OK的
經濟基本面還是運行的可以的
那麼為什麼運行的還可以呢
那麼你回頭看manufacturing這裡面有製造業
這個製造業16k
然後construction 22k
製造業16k裡面
那個有大概6k是
就是metal就是金屬機械
那這一些東西增加的工作崗位
本身就是跟數據中心建設是有關的
manufacturing16k裡面有8000個人
是none resolution
就非住宅性的裡面也是跟建數據中心有關
那麼你看分區的話
你看那個賀皮書分區的話
你看那個經濟比較好的地方
其實都是在建數據中心的地方
也就是現在K-shape的經濟是非常明顯的
在實體裡面能夠獲得那麼一點動力的
也是那個AI這個IC包蔓延出來的一些東西
所以你會看到製造業
製造業 建築行業
它真正在這個能狂配合中間
看上去還是比較好的
也是很大程度上是被數據中心帶動
那麼finance 金融info tag
那麼就是在AI的反面
等於AI取代它的人工
你看它就是負的
如果回頭看經濟基本面
是不是現在基本面支持一個加息
我覺得如果你光看wash的發言
那個星期四的時候有個water的發言
water的意思是說我們再給本週五的cpi數據一次機會
我們決定要不要等
但是wash當然相對來說比較強硬一點
就是說我們現在通常還沒完全得到控制
但是你看他們發言
你可能覺得就是會加息
555開吧 或者是大概的會加息
但是即使加息
我覺得要問兩個問題
第一個是說
這個加息是不是一個持續性的
像二年這樣的加息
那麼第二個問題是
這個加息是不是一個無序的加息
然後我會來解釋這兩件事
那麼這兩個事情哪怕都發生
它對於資本市場的影響是不是就一定是個crash
是不是一個一定的crash
我覺得這是從兩個問題和一個結果來看這件事情
然後我先說第一個
就是說它能不能做一個持續性的加息
那麼consumer credit
house handling就是我消費者的信貸
然後消費過消費信貸
帶動消費過熱
這是不是帶動就原來的經濟廠
是不是帶動經濟經濟成長
帶動CPI的一個核心因素
我們看到consumer credit在上升
這代表經濟經濟在負足
就是相對比方說前一段時間在負足
但是遠遠沒有達到上一次降息的時候
21年22年的水平
所以並並不是說
包括你看到前面那個工資上漲
工資上漲那一輪的
就是21年22年那一輪的工資上漲是非常猛烈的
不是3%
就7%這樣的速度上漲
所以我們沒有看到工資大規模的上漲
我們沒有看到消費信貸大規模增加
這一輪的所謂的同漲更多的是輸入性的
輸入性的你去加息本身沒有什麼用
你可以減少加息去減少同漲的預期
但是它不是一個持續性的加息
就是不是像20年這種持續性的
一個step一個step加
然後加到經濟基本面
酷蕩降下來
然後把那個同漲加下來
你現在經濟基本面降下來
你同漲也降不下來了
你是輸入性的嗎
那石油降到200塊錢跟你能有關係嗎
沒有什麼關係
石油真正的需求的減少
是中國人在減少
就中國在為伊朗的這個戰爭一直在買單
對吧
你美國本身也沒有買單
你也不是石油進口供
你是石油出口供
那個關稅
關稅輸入的東西
你你需求減少
能夠能夠把關稅的影響降低了嗎
也也不行
那關稅是他自己已經沒有了
但是這些輸入的影響
我意思就不是說加息能夠解決的
所以其實市場在pricing多少加息呢
市場在pricing大概到一年一年的話
一年一年大概是兩兩次到兩次半加息
到那個啊
到到二七二八年
那麼一年一年就兩年嘛
兩年現在到二八年八月份
二八年八月份到這裡
大概pricing2.5次加息
那麼這個加息的幅度
和你們認為經濟很熱
就真正過熱
然後美聯儲需要嚇阻利息
加息的幅度是一樣的
也就是現在加息3號
我認為被pricing
就我們今天講的所有的加息的問題
然後cabin wash有可能會變得強硬
然後我們看到一個更好的經濟數據
我不知道經濟記憶物的這個CPI怎麼樣
我認為經濟記憶物的CPI不會太差
就是不會太差的意思就是
它不會
不會不會那個很高
就這意思不會不會太差
然後原因嘛
就是說你工資也沒漲
對吧
然後consumer spending漲了也沒漲很多
所以我覺得CPI不會太差
但是即使它不好
那麼我們認為它會加息
它不是一個長序的加息
steadily的加息
這是這是影響市場的第一個問題
當你市場的加息
不是一個無序的狀態
你怕的加息是它無序
它通脹很高
它被迫快速加息
被迫快速加息導致利率倒掛
就是我長端利率低於短端利率
我curve flatten
其實curve flatten比curve stipend還差
對比經濟要衰退了嘛
我短期的經短期借錢
我沒有人短期借錢
為長期的東西去工作了
然後curve flatten這種情況
我覺得相對來說更加危險一點
但是現在沒有這個
沒有能夠把curve打flatten的那種
就變平的那種加息的這個速度在哪裡
我覺得暫時錢手上是沒有的
這是第一個問題
那麼第二個問題是
我加息的時候是不是無序的
無序的意思就是我很急
20年這種那個我因為通脹很高
所以我要快速加息
把通脹給壓下去
而且當時通脹是失控了
開始失控了
一下子疫情打開
疫情時候放了太多的錢
主要是放了太多的財政政策
consumer spending很高
然後工資的上漲很快
所以它是快速加息
你可以看到一個無序加息的特徵
是它的wall上升得很快
這個是6 month 10 year
就是6個月以後10年的swapping
那當6個月為期限的一個10年
為標的這麼一個期權的一個波動率
那麼6 month 10 year的wall
在當時快速加息的時候升了很快
所以我們是不是一個經濟體
就是說回過來說
但現在沒有
現在是比較平穩
雖然利率一直在穩固的往上跑
就是在最近一段時間
利率一直在穩固往上跑
但是它的wall沒有上升
那我們之前也講過這個
就是利率本身並不直接代表它對資產
有資產巨大的衝擊
利率可以去調整資產的估值
調整你的multiple
那我們已經被調整
我們前兩個星期都看到
我們前幾個星期看到
它已經被調整了
但是multiple已經被調整
但是它不代表你會帶來一個巨大的下跌
這樣的下跌往往是intrested wall帶來的
就是你無序的在加息
或者你無序的失控的長端
你長端不管往上失控往下失控
你失控
你就容易導致整個資本市場流動性
衝擊導致資本市場去槓桿
等等
那麼現在在利率市場上
這兩點都看不到的情況下
即使它穩固的利率在往上跑
其實你回頭可以看
那個加息完了那段時間
利率往上跑
除了21年之後
就21年快速加息之後
等到它不平定了
然後23年之後市場並不差的
就是你整個資本市場並不是很差
所以不能夠直接把利率升高
和加息挖等號
然後第三件事情我要說的是
這次加不加息沒有那麼差
為什麼呢
也就像我們前兩次講過的就是
當然把加息的概率往上跑了
這就我們剛剛看到
把加息概率往上跑
加不加息沒有那麼重要
就是利率其實要去符合你的長期的增長
然後以前其實一直是符合的
只是到了2008年以後
大家開始印了更多的錢
所以長期的話有一個1%到2%差價
你要把這個差價給補上
那長單利率就應該跑到6秒說
但是跑到6又怎麼樣
就80年代時候我們不增長了
80年代時候美國經濟是增長
那個利率是8%
它不增長嗎
它一樣增長
真正改變的是一個什麼東西呢
真正的改變的是2000年左右
那個時候利率基本上和Normano GDP差不多的
2000年
資本市場泡沫泡沫面
到了08年
那個quadrock crisis
那個規律財政規律
之後整個經濟增長的動力
變成了硬潛
就是我們不是效率提高
你說回頭看美國
美國從2008年之後
2008年之後
它人口沒有增長第一
第二 經濟效率沒有增長
整個西方社會都是這樣子
經濟效率沒有增長
人口沒有增長的時候
它怎麼維持原來2%的經濟增長
它必須要靠流動性去維持
硬潛
然後要硬潛
它就不能夠把這個利率調到和Normano GDP growth一樣
所以它要人為的去做日本做YCC
美國要做就是長端利率控制
要做QE
其實它們的目的都是一樣
就是我要硬出更多的錢
我讓硬出的錢和GDP中間有個差價
拿這個東西來帶動經濟增長
那麼這個東西像吸毒
但是你慢慢越吸越中越吸越中
從吸煙開始到吸毒
這個是一個確定的過程
那麼但是現在AI發生以後
其實幾十年來第一次
真正的效率在提高
這是一次產業的個案
效率在提高的時候
我們就要adjust ourself
就是我們要把自己調整到
去能夠適應這個新的增長到週期
這個新的增長週期
它效率在提高
所以它利率就應該更高
它就應該
然後說CAMERWATCH它們的主張
它就不應該去管長端
它如果不管長端
那長端就應該跟Normano GDP差不多
只是說在這個KSHIP的經濟增長的狀態裡面
我們不知道它最後是維持在現在水平
Normano是6到6.5
還是說像狗們預測的
我長端的需求也是會下來
我長端GDP也要下了
要下到4.8 4.7
那麼我們現在利率就是合理
就是這個我們是不確定
但是我們確定的是
在這個KSHIP裡面
往上那個是效率很高的
就是它不在乎你5%還是6%還是7%
甚至8%它都不在乎
在經濟體是一個加權平均
所以往下那個是在乎的
往上那個是不在乎的
你利率升高
你是殺傷往下的
就是KSHIP下面那個
然後因為你的經濟體能夠忍受更高
因為我們的效率在提高
我們的經濟基本面增長在提高
所以最終能夠獲利的
就是說最終我們能夠忍受一個更高的利率
就長端更高的利率
只要這個利率不是失控了
你它的問題是它失控
就是你忽然間加息
然後導致它很長得很快
所以我身後還有個感覺
就是你說Belson的在長端
比方說那個財政部在長端
他很在乎長端利率
他是控制長端利率
這一周就有實驗期火炸藥法
他並不是他並不是就是新
幾乎拉火的
一定要去把長端壓下來
他也做不到
他是通過財政部的這個9期的調整
來讓長端不要失控
就不要產生過大的波動率
長端真正能走到哪裡
這個東西其實不是財政部能決定的
長端真正走到哪裡
是那個其實是那個Tamel Wash
是那個美聯儲決定
那麼美聯儲現在感覺的態度
它對於長端其實是要想交給市場
我們之前好早之前就講過這個問題
他想交給市場
所以他想交給市場
最後利率跑到哪裡去
決定了你的GDP在哪裡跑到哪裡去
他什麼也不做
就是做最多的事情
這個我好像之前也正要提過這個事情
就是原來我都是管著長端利率
然後我一直在硬前控制它
現在我忽然之間一天我告訴你不硬了
那不硬這件事情就是一個巨大的動作
對吧
那麼這種情況下長端是去找GDP的
所以你短端是不是神系
生多少次利息
我覺得影響不大
並不存在我短端生了利息
然後控制住長端
控制不住的
長端一定跟著GDP走
但是另外也不存在的
長端往上跑了
然後市場就崩掉
市場不可能崩掉
因為你是一個在經濟增長週期
經濟效率提高的週期
持續的把利率justify到你經濟增長的規模
經濟增長的速度
所以在這個過程中間是以救換新
新的替代救的
新的增長更高的獲得更多的資源
這個是很正常
50年代我們也經歷過
更早的時候也經歷過
然後其實森浩我覺得
2000年其實沒有很大的提高經濟效率
但是2000年之後這段週期也經歷過
只是原來的
就是我們說Multiple在被改變
Multiple這個事情
並不是我之前講的稍微有一點
那個我覺得有點confusing
就是Multiple在往下跑
S&P的Multiple在往下跑
但是Multiple這個東西並不是一成不變的
而是說這個增長率
Multiple比方說P的Multiple20
這個20是對應增長率的
對應相同增長率情況下的Multiple
是要往下跳的
那你很正常嗎
我現在產業革命了嗎
我們在鐵路時代
能夠有5%的增長
就鐵路之前
一戰之前世界有2%到3%的增長
就很了不起增長非常非常快
因為那個時候經濟就是這個速度
是真正是到了二戰之後
我們才會看到5%的失蹤增長
因為有不停的產業革命
科技革命科技進步
然後科技的紅利
導致的我們增長變更快
也就是P這個東西
是跟我的增長是相關的
就是我比方說
我原來15%的增長
我給你20倍P
現在我要20%的增長
才給你20倍P
但是對於很多AI相關的公司
你還倒比我5倍
它會在乎在乎說
你們P adjustment
你P 我要調
跟我沒有影響
半導體裡面比比介紹
半導體裡面增長90%比比介紹
那個英偉達增長70%
英偉達增長70%
人家不是現在還拿了12倍P嗎
P是在被壓縮
但是呢
它就說這個增長高的公司
還是會在裡面獲得更多的P
只是現在處於一個比較混亂的狀態
因為英偉達的市值太高了
大家要想想
你好像不能夠搞到10萬億
但是它會搞到10萬億
就是早晚的問題
因為你不能夠一直把一個增長70
毛利70的公司壓到12倍P
這個是不合理的
所以在一堆混亂結束之後
整個Multiple的下調是對應於現在的增長
但是經濟發展
就是我們的AI發展
我們的技術發展
是會導致我們有新的P的Node
不好意思
這個是日本的
現在新的經濟成長
是會給我們的新的P的Node
所以我們過程中間面臨的一個
叫做rate利率成構
面臨的增長的成構
就增長成構
導致了我們利率成構
同時的話導致風險資產的Multiple的成構
Multiple成構是市場
簡單來說
市場需要更高的成長
所以我們回過來講
前幾個週我們都講過這問題
就是投資的時候
盡量避開增長不夠的公司
你既然是新的科技發展的這個週期裡面
那你就要去買值得
這個就是能夠匹配這個經濟增長週期
這科技週期
新的增速的這些公司要有增速
當你沒有增速的時候
你的Multiple就是往下跑
因為整個經濟體的增速在偏快
相信美國原來比方說實際是2.5
這個2.5是靠著硬體研究出來的
現在經濟增長本身能給你帶到2.5
大到3 大到4
就是先新的經濟增長本身
就是我們AI能夠把你帶上去
所以這個過程裡面
那麼我們實際增長率變更高了
那我需要能夠侵賴的資產
你至少能跑贏他們嗎
要跑贏更多吧
所以這個是我覺得是一個投資的新的環境
那麼真正的問題處在哪裡
問題處在Rates都在跑高
AI並不是指利航美國
AI的生產用半導體也利航中國
也利航日本
你有韓國
然後你就歐洲
歐洲相對弱一點
就最差的是歐洲百貨位
就是但是整體歐洲也要省息
也就是產業革命帶動的增長變速
增長變速
背後就是利率要缺GS的一個情況上
那麼真正出問題處在誰處
處在日本頭上
就是你可以看到過去的那個債務率
那美國也沒怎樣
中國當然更高三百多
中國拋開
我們人民幣擁有無敵的
但是把那個中國拋開
日本的債務率其實非常高
就國債率非常高
所以日本也同樣面臨的問題
就是GDP Expected GDP
就Normal GDP和十年利率的
這個可能話錯了
對就是 Expected GDP和十年利率這個差別
雖然它只差0.2
但是它的Inflation Expectation
就是Inflation Swap
就是那個我的通脹的預期很高
所以你的利率還要去滿足這個預期
在這個過程中間
利率已經上升很多
你能3%
利率預期再往上跑的話
才3.5%
你不要看這一點
日本利率基本上是零升上來的
這個過程裡面會讓日本的金融機構
蒙受巨大的損失
所有的錢 債券 國債
全部在金融機構上
大家都預期
收益就那麼一點點
安倍經濟就不停的印錢來解決
然後印錢來解決我的
金融公司的Balance Sheet受到影響
相反
美國大的金融公司
因為經歷過08年
在上一輪升息
周期就2004年的時候
Celicon百里版可以也倒了
美國的小銀行已經受過一輪損失了
大銀行為什麼沒受損失
大銀行風險管理表
大銀行其實一直要把這個風險
就是我們叫Duration Risk
是要求被他踢出去的
然後美國的
你就算升息
其實到4.8
你現在把1到4.8
1到4.8的過程中年
那個大規模的國債減損已經發生
然後這個Dole
在過24年到現在
開始慢慢已經補差不多了
已經補了兩年了
就是
但是日本現在開始繼續要往上升
而且它的債務比率更高
所以真正
我覺得如果你們擔心美國出問題
我覺得問題可能會更大的
其實日本
當然
但這個日本也都是內戰
他們也可以去採取硬體
跟我們互相辦法
但是美國當時在解決Celicon百里版
和地區性銀行
因為美持有大量美債
然後美債在貶值
在貶值等於從一年級
開始跑到4.5
這個過程中間一直在貶值
你解決這個問題的時候
通脹預期沒那麼高
所以J-PAL當時還是能過硬潛解決的
但是日本現在
就比歐傑相對來說比較難過
因為現在這個週期已經不太一樣
這個週期更多的是往上的
所以你怕的是
這個週期
在增長的週期裡面
然後有通脹預期
你還不太敢去硬潛
然後另外一邊
你不太敢去硬潛
國債就跌
國債往上跑就開始跌
國債一跌的話
你就全部要壞賬
所以這個才是日本更多來說
更大的問題
所以我是覺得安倍
就是安倍經濟學
安倍經濟學
其實相同的辦法
之前也用在美國
大家都是靠硬潛
中國也是
中國到現在都是這麼搞
就是大家靠硬潛來解決增長的問題
在通縮的經濟環境裡面
用硬潛解決增長的問題
通縮的環境的誘因是人口
然後是生產效率沒有提高
但是在AI裡面
生產效率提高太快了
雖然安倍經濟學
就全球實施的安倍經濟學
都要掉頭
那麼歐洲這次可能會加息
但是加息是不是
一定代表經濟傳統
我覺得不少
所以我覺得兩點關注的看的
就是因為
效率確實在提高
經濟增長是實體經濟增長變強
利率有沒有失去
就inflation ball
這個swapping ball
有沒有利率有沒有失去
利率升上升
它的波動力有沒有失去
它是不是一個持續的過程
如果不是的話
穩步的利率上升調整
只是市場價格的調整
有沒有那麼大的問題
然後說一下
上兩個星期的position
市場的倉位
prambo的倉位
對於momentum的持倉一直在提高
你可以看到這條黑顏色
黑顏色就TMT
TMT momentum
prambo就對沖基金
其實一直在買入
也就是我們在大規模的
去槓桿結束
在7月份去槓桿結束
雖然前兩個星期有
andopic的65個別臉的這個鬼故事
但是無論這些鬼故事發生
prambo都是在買入
而且現在整體的倉位比較低
你看這個圖
好像上週我們也講過
整個gross margin
還是來說gross margin和net margin
雙雙相對來說比較低
你看我那個圖也是一樣
你看這個一年
就是5 balance
我看一下
什麼時候現在
prambo剛剛就在這裡
你可以看一年的話
它其實現在也在一個高位下調
其實調了有5月份到現在
調了三個月
然後nap position跟年初的時候
是差不多的
就是鏡頭寸差不多
總槓桿
可能現在跟3月份差不多
所以包括我們看到
andopic65個別臉的這個消息出來以後
對市場衝擊
就是這個衝擊是有限的
也就是說明
我們看到的AI相關的動能票
繼續往下跌的力量已經不大
這就是市場的一個反饋搞水
並不是說我一定跌到多少
比方說我看那個
看那個momancon的倉位跌了多少
而是說其實momancon的倉位
現在在這麼多的這個
在那個andopic65別臉的負面消息出來以後
其實不是很雜的動
那麼這個就說明
就是基本上到頭了
就跟7月份的時候
9月份的時候
8月份的時候
你看那個韓國的
韓國的那個槓桿
韓國槓桿就是去不動了
那去不動我就就差不多了
所以整體
我覺得短期position來說
還是比較支持AI的
然後AI這些公司的估值的話
你如果看簡單的談估值
其實他們的估值現在都還算
就估值在增長的情況下的估值
都還是比較低
所以我回到我剛才的觀點
就K shape
現在估值上往下的條賴
才是增長上往上的條賴
那條腿
所以這個市場一個錯配
都是我覺得是一個機會
然後最後我說一下
那個為什麼momentum還有到底的
就是還有一個原因
就是我們看momentum的話
你可以看到所有的Vol在下降
就是利率的Vol沒有上去在下降
你別管生息
這個東西都pricing
就是你現在如果覺得
大家有無需的生息
那Vol馬上上去
利率的Vol沒有變化
說明其實大家對這個東西已經pricing
沒有很大的問題
第二個
acquittable股票的Vol
股票Vol也一路在下降
這個不光是指數
single stop的
就單股的Vol下降速度更快
單股的Vol下降速度
你可能從那個
我們有個AI的basket
那不是這些條
就是我大概有20 30個票AI basket
然後這20 30個票AI basket
那Vol是一路下降到了65
所以我剛正好在開會前
我們的說就是如果正常的話
你如果用Vol control策略的話
Vol control策略的話
可能你就現在已經全
就已經基本上是不全倉了
Vol肯就現在肯定不全倉
因為Vol在下降
然後你看到的各個公司的Vol
我們看一下
一個月的一個星期的impliable
就是這個是這些公司
就這些公司
然後這些大概一共
我除了這上面
大概還有20 30個
然後這些AI相關的公司的Vol
就幾百人跌了一半
星期五的時候稍微上去一點
但是我覺得沒有
沒有往上打破比方說
大幅上升的平台
所以整體從倉位和Momentum這些來看的話
我覺得Momentum基本上處於
去港版去不動的狀態
所以就我回頭講
大家都擔心的一件事情
比方說深吸會導致市場崩潰
因為大家看到是2000年
深吸的時候導致市場崩潰
市場永遠會重演
但是它結果不會
結果不會一模一樣
所以你覺得2000年深吸要崩潰
這次深吸了
可能深吸
但它不一定會崩潰
2000年和現在有個本質的區別
2000年的時候體系外是沒有錢進來的
唯一可能收到一點錢
的是亞馬遜當時
賣點書
還賣點什麼東西的
然後在現在的話
體系外其實花的錢是很多的
就是不是在AI圈裡面體系外
比如說Coling或者研究
這些花的錢是很多的
和當時還是有本質的區別
我是看了很多CSP
就是Hyperscalatum
什麼Microsoft Google Amazon
他們手上的這些數據
我覺得更加有信心
也就是說
他們這些公司並不是小公司
並不是2000年的時候
那些科技公司小公司
恰恰
他們是經歷過2000年
現在萬億級的公司
幾萬億的公司
他們給出的預期是負責的
我就這麼說
就你們如果覺得2000年
這個預期這些都不負責
最後左腳踩右腳都崩掉
但是他們並不是這樣的
它也並不是根據Andopic和OpenAI的需求
然後來定自己明年要做多少Compax
它是根據自己
Microsoft自己就是個大Sales
它自己手上有所有的Copycoco
它是根據它自己手上的東西
然後來認為AI有多少
所以它給出這個預期
我覺得是負責任
然後最後說一下Andopic的AR
65個別臉的問題
我覺得有兩種原因
就是現在市場上說兩個原因
它為什麼65個別臉
比我們之前預期的要少
我們這邊給AR的
看了這個AN Lab的數據
其實之前一直在說
已經到了70個別臉
到了70幾個別臉
線性外推可能到了70幾個別臉
調整的原因我覺得幾個
口徑的調整
就是現在出來說一個口徑調整
因為中國人一直在蒸餾它
所以它把中國人蒸餾它的這些頭肯給划掉
因為你是在抄襲我划了頭肯
不能算在不慎算真實的需求裡
這是一個
第二個它表示通過OpenAI
它通過Amazon去賣的話
給Amazon要封城的
你可以說我賣了100
然後賣了100
然後這100全部算成我的收入
然後我把Net給摳掉
然後給Amazon比方說35是
然後給Amazon35是摳掉給Amazon
但是其實
至少你作為要上市的時候
你即將不能這麼計
所以你要把這個標準統一
就說很有可能這個Anthopia的這數字
就是這個市場上說兩個
一個是去掉蒸餾
然後第二個是把它口徑
按照上市口徑的統一
把你應該成本
你是賣頭肯的成本給划掉
所以並不是65個別連
那個比方說主要就是7月份那個數據
7月份的數據
然後真的變了很差
然後其實並不是這樣
當然Anthopia的這個
Token的增速是必然下降
下降的原因是因為它貴
它的毛利太高了
它毛利可能90
它毛利90
那麼為什麼
像那個Microsoft一樣賣算力給你的
它會覺得為什麼不賣開源模型呢
我開源模型賣了這個90
毛利不是我自己的嗎
Microsoft賣的並不比它便宜
這個是市場非常樂觀的一個點
Microsoft賣的Token也不會比Open AI便宜
並不是在打價格戰
而是說它用它自己的平臺
能夠更好整合它的客戶
它能賣得更貴
這個才是更樂觀的東西
好吧
我今天可能就先講到這裏
我看時間差不多了
好吧
謝謝大家的時間